So thank you for checking out today's Unreal Engine training on world partition techniques
and applications in 5.0.
We've covered a lot of ground with a lot of features, so we talked about the world partition
and what it is, how to get set up using world partition in your templates, and also just
how to enable it in your projects if you have existing projects where you didn't use a template.
We covered all the different tools that come with world partition, and then we also gave
a couple of debug commands at the end.
So hopefully you found that useful to just get an overview of what world partition is
and how you might use it in your projects.
So thank you again for watching, and we'll see you in the next video.